i
[Música]
ucrania perdió la comunicación con
quienes estaban atrincherados en la
siderúrgica a sus talent mariupol justo
cuando la alcaldía dice que los rusos
los están atacando más fuerte aunque
moscú lo niegan en el día 70 de la
guerra encontraron más cuerpos en la
región de kiev
tendremos reportes desde ucrania
la presidenta de la comisión europea
dice que rusia debe pagar por su
invasión mientras la unión europea
propone embargar las importaciones de su
petróleo crudo y refinado como una nueva
sanción aunque la medida debe ser
aprobada por los 27 países para entrar
en vigor desde ya se opuso hungría una
nación altamente dependiente del
petróleo
y la interrupción del embarazo será un
tema central en las elecciones de medio
término en eeuu
ahora que se conoció un borrador que
estima que la corte suprema de justicia
tiene una opinión a favor de anular el
histórico fallo del roe versus way que
hace del aborto un derecho
constitucional en el país la popularidad
del presidente joe biden se recupera
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
saludarlos y empezamos a esta emisión
informativa en ucrania el alcalde de la
sitiada ciudad de mariupol vadim
boychenko afirmó que ya no tienen
comunicación con los militares y civiles
que resisten en la acería as hostal
además las autoridades ucranianas
sostienen que la arremetida rusa aumentó
y por primera vez atacaron la fábrica
con tanques sin embargo moscú lo niega y
dice que sólo está repeliendo los
ataques otra de las denuncias es que el
kremlin se estaría preparando para
conmemorar el día de la victoria en
mariupol un festejo en la que todos los
9 de mayo los rusos celebran la victoria
contra la alemania nazi en la segunda
guerra mundial por otra parte
encontraron 20 cuerpos en boro dianca
con lo que se suman mil 235 cadáveres
hallados en la región de kiev desde la
retirada de las tropas rusas
y en medio de los ataques cientos de
personas lograron evacuar de la planta
siderúrgica en mariupol y ahora después
de dos días de camino llegaron a la
vecina ciudad de sabor' y allá la vice
primera ministra ucraniana irina
bereziuk afirmó que en la fábrica siguen
miles de personas atrapadas incluidos
menores de edad nuestra vida especial
catalina gómez ángel nos cuenta más
desde sap orilla
este parqueadero a la entrada a la
ciudad de sap orilla se ha convertido en
el lugar soñado de miles y miles de
personas que huyen de ciudades en el sur
de ucrania no sólo de mariupol donde
llegaban más de 130 personas que huían
de la ciudad sino también de otras
ciudades que están en control de las
fuerzas rusas desde hace ya varias
semanas como melitópol y verdad este es
el caso de tamara este plan a que
llegaron hoy
vicky muy pic y es difícil irse es
difícil y probablemente la mayoría de la
gente no quiera irse por eso es muy
difícil ellos los rusos podemos decirlo
de esta manera son muy abruptos
ellos exigen tarjetas sin auriculares
cigarrillos revisan los teléfonos
revisaron todas mis fotos todos los
chats de telegram y buscaban la bandera
ucraniana o cualquier cosa relacionada
con la simbología ucraniana
en este parqueadero se sigue esperando
que más personas puedan huir de esas
herida de azúcar donde cientos de
personas siguen todavía en esos refugios
subterráneos y están asediadas por esas
fuerzas rusas sin embargo poco a poco
van llegando vehículos privados de
personas que al lograr logrado huir de
la ciudad es que no lo pueden hacer
directamente tienen que ir a una ciudad
de verdad es que el poder de las fuerzas
rusas allí ir pasando cada uno de esos
retenes más de 17 del ejército ruso con
las dificultades hasta poder llegar
hasta aquí hay personas que se tardan
incluso tres o cuatro días la comisión
europea propuso su sexto y más duro
paquete de sanciones contra rusia una de
las medidas planteadas es prohibir la
importación del crudo ruso dentro de
seis meses y de los petróleos refinados
en un año aunque plantean excepciones
para países altamente dependientes como
eslovaquia y hungría este último se
opuso a la propuesta alba santana tiene
los detalles
es uno de los mayores paquetes de
sanciones contra rusia propuesto hasta
el momento el nuevo golpe de la unión
europea contra el gobierno de putin va
dirigido a su petróleo un reto también
para el bloque por su dependencia
energética del exterior
seamos claros y easy
no será fácil porque algunos estados
miembros dependen en gran medida del
petróleo ruso pero simplemente debemos
hacerlo así que hoy proponemos prohibir
todo el petróleo ruso en europa rayón o
el cambio la idea es ir reduciendo
progresivamente las importaciones y
compra de petróleo ruso en los próximos
seis meses hasta anular las por completo
para finales de año además de esta
prohibición el grupo de los 27 planea
sanciones contra altos cargos y
militares que participaron en la matanza
de lucha y el asedio a mariupol la
expulsión de más entidades bancarias del
sistema swift y la suspensión de la
emisión de cadenas de televisión
asociadas al gobierno ruso algo que no
convence a todos los miembros de la
unión europea ya que países como hungría
y bulgaria son fuertemente
del petróleo que enviamos
y
hungría sólo podría aceptar esas
sanciones y el transporte de crudo por
oleoducto quedará exento en este caso se
mantendría el suministro energético de
hungría como esto no es así el paquete
no puede ser apoyado responsablemente
en esta línea la unión europea planea
aplicar excepciones para estos países
una vez aprobadas las sanciones no
obstante la propuesta debe obtener el
visto bueno de los 27 para poder entrar
en vigor
pasamos a eeuu una campaña que se
preveía iba a estar marcada por la
guerra en ucrania dio su giro luego de
que se filtrara el borrador de la
opinión de la corte suprema de justicia
sobre el derecho a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo ahora el
mandatario joe biden y su partido el
demócrata ganan la popularidad de cara a
las elecciones de medio término que se
celebrarán en noviembre y en las que se
renovarán un tercio de la cámara de
representantes y la totalidad del senado
mientras tanto crecen las críticas hacia
el partido republicano pues el
ex-presidente donald trump dominó a dos
jueces conservadores que llegaron al
máximo tribunal
en varias ciudades de eeuu los
manifestantes se tomaron las calles
indignados su ira dirigida a la corte
suprema tras la filtración del borrador
de una opinión que sugería que el órgano
judicial estaría a punto de anular el
fallo histórico de roe versus wade de
1973 que estableció el aborto como un
derecho constitucional da miedo es
devastador pero definitivamente estoy
motivada para seguir luchando y nos
aseguraremos de que el acceso al aborto
permanezca no se trata sólo del aborto
se parará el control y ahora estamos
viendo que el control se nos va y no lo
toleramos mientras estos manifestantes
luchan para que se mantengan los
derechos de las mujeres a decidir
algunos estados ya se están preparando
para una nueva era si se anulara el
fallo histórico el derecho a interrumpir
el embarazo se dejaría en manos de los
legisladores estatales y los líderes de
estados conservadores ya están listos
para convocar a sesiones legislativas
especiales para prohibir el
procedimiento si el tribunal supremo
revoca la sentencia
el gobernador de oklahoma firmó un
proyecto de ley que prohíbe el aborto
después de seis semanas coincidiendo con
una ley similar en texas gobernadores
demócratas en estados como california
anunciaron rápidamente planes para
consagrar el derecho al aborto en la ley
local un movimiento alentado por el
presidente joe biden su administración
pide a la corte suprema que proteja el
acceso al aborto
como se atreven a decirle a una mujer lo
que puede y no puede hacer con su propio
cuerpo como se atreven a tratar de
evitar que determine su propio futuro
como se atreven a negar a las mujeres
sus derechos y libertades
el borrador no es una sentencia
definitiva por lo tanto no es seguro que
se revierta la histórica decisión a
pesar de una mayoría conservadora en la
corte suprema- una encuesta del
washington post y el vice news encontró
que sólo el 28 por ciento de los
estadounidenses cree que la decisión de
1973 debería ser anulada
en una decisión histórica de la reserva
federal de eeuu aumentó las tasas de
interés en medio punto porcentual el
incremento más grande que ha anunciado
desde el 2000 kieron favor del
presidente de la fed por sus siglas en
inglés explicó que las medidas para
hacerle frente a la peor inflación que
ha enfrentado el país en 40 años
en noticias de américa latina' el
parlamento nicaragüense de mayoría
oficialista canceló la representación
legal de 50 ongs así ya han suspendido a
187 organizaciones desde diciembre de
2018 el ministerio de gobernación acusa
a las organizaciones de no reportar sus
estados financieros sin embargo
entidades como amnistía internacional
han denunciado que es una de las maneras
del oficialismo para perseguir a sus
opositores
y en francia se consolida cada vez más
la unión de la izquierda para las
elecciones legislativas del 12 y 19 de
junio la francia y su misa de jean-luc
mélenchon y el partido socialista
alcanzaron un principio de acuerdo para
formar una coalición luego de que los
comunistas y los ecologistas salieran
con el partido de izquierda más votado
en las presidenciales así los cuatro
colectivos quieren hacerle contrapeso al
poder del presidente manuel marco en la
asamblea nacional
una semana de negociaciones entre la
francia insumisa y el partido socialista
con resultados esta noche y conocidos
tras el anuncio del diputado adrián 2 de
esta mañana
socialista un principio de acuerdo entre
delegaciones corresponde al partido
socialista validarlo nyon nacional del
partido socialista
y ese es el problema del partido
socialista la dinámica para unirse a la
coalición de izquierdas de cara a las
elecciones legislativas genera mucha
polémica interna
este partido de gobierno que ha dominado
la vida política durante 50 años corre
el riesgo de fracturarse dividiéndose
entre los que seguirán con mccrone los
que se irán por su cuenta y los que se
sumarán al acuerdo
foxit irak o en efecto muchos militantes
temen perder las responsabilidades
locales que aún están en manos de los
socialistas
las figuras del partido como el
exministro de interior bernanke asnef
amenazan con abandonarlo alegando ideas
políticas incompatibles con la francia
insumisa para todos aquellos que van a
ser candidatos de todos los modos porque
no aceptan este acuerdo tenemos que
hacer esta campaña según el acuerdo con
la francia e insumisa unos 70
socialistas serían investidos para las
elecciones legislativas es decir mucha
más representación que la lograda con el
resultado de anne hidalgo en las
elecciones presidenciales internamente
los negociadores socialistas habrían
aceptado buena parte del programa común
aunque la cuestión de la desobediencia a
las normas europeas sigue como un
importante punto de divergencia
desde hoy comienzan las celebraciones
por el aniversario número 74 de la
creación del estado de israel el primer
ministro naftalí bennett lideró un
llamado a la unidad repetido por los
líderes políticos israelíes sin embargo
la fecha está marcada por la dualidad
porque para muchos árabes recuerda el
éxodo palestino forzado por el
establecimiento del estado judío nuestro
corresponsal en jerusalén federico que
barberena nos trae el reporte
día 5 de liar en el calendario hebreo y
del luto por el recuerdo de sus soldados
caídos y víctimas del terrorismo israel
pasa a celebrar el aniversario 74 de la
creación de su estado la conmemoración
de este año ocurre de la noche del
miércoles a la jornada del jueves inició
con el encendido de antorchas en el
monte herzl y cuenta con diversos
eventos culturales y la realización de
picnics barbacoas y conciertos entre
otros actos de que por primera vez en
dos años se desarrollan casi sin
restricciones por la pandemia
esto es muy emocionante extrañaba salir
a las calles y celebrar israel para mí
israel significa independencia y
libertad para ser judía para estar en la
calle y estar orgulloso de mí y de mis
creencias
a esta fecha el gobierno israelí llega
al mando de una coalición con inédita
presencia árabe algo destacado por el
primer ministro naftalí bennett en su
mensaje aunque marcado por su fragilidad
y lejos de estar dispuesto a un diálogo
serio que resuelva el conflicto entre
israelíes y palestinos para estos
últimos este día no es de festejo o
independencia sino que marca la nakba o
catástrofe en referencia al hecho de
forzado que cientos de miles de
palestinos sufrieron desde la guerra
árabe-israelí de 1948 hasta hoy
si me preguntas por mis sentimientos
como árabe este es mi país y no me
siento tranquilo porque vivo en
condiciones difíciles sobre todo con los
judíos
no nos sentimos con libertad de ir a
donde queramos y hacer lo que queramos
dv
la controversia en torno a este día
sumar a este jueves una exhibición de la
fuerza aérea israelí que planea
sobrevolar hebrón en la cisjordania
ocupada un movimiento catalogado de
provocación por la izquierda israelí y
organizaciones palestinas
cuánto pagaría usted por una camiseta
del futbolista argentino diego armando
maradona cuéntenos en redes sociales por
ahora nosotros les contamos que la
prenda que vestía el delantero en el gol
conocido como la mano de dios acaba de
ser vendida por más de 9 millones de
dólares el ex futbolista inglés steve
hodge era el dueño de la camiseta desde
que maradona se la regaló en los cuartos
de final del mundial de méxico por
muchos años la cedió al museo nacional
del fútbol en manchester y ahora decidió
venderla pero todavía se desconoce quién
la compró
hasta aquí las noticias sigan en france